(audience clapping)
Hi, hi everybody.
Let me tell something.
Since she's done your show,
she can't shut up about Drew Barrymore.
That's all I hear about.
That's all, that's the entire topic of our house right now.
I'm so relieved.
I feel a little that's crazy
because I'm just wild about her.
And I have such admiration for both of you.
Thank you, what a nice thing to say, Drew.
I appreciate it.
Fun fact, I was with Steven Spielberg
and he had to go see, we had to go to Westwood
to see a trailer for his movie.
And "Footloose" was playing.
And like people were literally hanging
from chandeliers in the movie theater.
It was like the coolest thing I've ever seen.
And like people were partying in the aisles.
That must feel good to know.
Well, you know I can remember very well the premier.
I was actually thinking about this the other day.
The premier of "Footloose" was in Westwood.
And partway through the premier night,
I started flipping out because to me it wasn't loud enough.
Like there was a problem with the audio in the theater.
And I thought to myself, oh, my God,
here's this movie that's just like so dependent
on having just a banging soundtrack,
just, you know, knocking your heads off.
And not to drop a name, but I will.
Afterwards, I was talking to Quincy Jones,
who was actually at the premiere.
And he said to me that when your adrenaline
is really flying off the chart,
that your ear automatically shuts down a lot of frequencies.
So it had nothing to do with the sound system.
It was just, it just had to do with the fact
that I was so nervous about the movie
that I couldn't actually hear it.
I love that.
Well, your most beautiful, cool, funny, amazing wife.
I guess I don't have to tell you, but I'm in love with her.
She was on the show two weeks ago
and she told us some fun, juicy stories.
Would you like to see some?
Sure, sure.
(audience laughing)
Are you talking about my Tom cruise story?
I was looking around and I was like,
ooh, a flat little button.
And he was like, you pressed that button?
And I said, yeah, I pressed that button.
And he goes, that's the panic button.
And so the cops came.
They had to stop the screening.
I did read that you and Kevin walk around the house naked
since you've been empty nesters.
Is this true?
Because I do it too!
I mean, more naked than usual.
But like, I wouldn't say we're naked all the time,
(laughing)
by any stretch.
I think you might have a story for us if you would share
that happened with your husband, Kevin Bacon.
It's about a bikini line wax that went awry.
Oh, my God, already I'm in!
(laughing)
I mean, honestly I can't go into the details.
But there was a moment where I thought
I can't pull the strip off.
Neither of us could figure out how to pull it off.
Do we need to go to the hospital?
Right.
(laughing)
What did you do when she pressed
the panic button at Tom Cruise's house?
What's your side of that story?
You know, I just apologized.
Like, oh honey, she's so, oh no.
There she goes again, pressing buttons.
(laughing)
Okay, how about the naked around the house,
now that I heard, and you guys became empty nesters?
I just got excited about this story
because when my kids go to their dad's house,
I totally walk around the house naked
in like excited rebellion that I have the joint to myself.
Listen, you know, as long as you have good curtains,
you know, good shades.
Okay, and then of course, the bikini wax story.
I mean, she said that you're just so handy
that she thought that you were the go to man.
And then it sounds like midway you were like,
oh gosh, I don't know what to do.
It made me really appreciate
what those trained professionals can do.
And it's the definition of kids, don't try this at home.
(laughing) Kids, don't try this at home
when you're naked in the house.
That must have made it all the quicker.
Okay, is it true that you bought two goats
as an anniversary present for Kyra?
Yeah, Macon is one of 'em, and Louie is the other.
And she certainly likes animals,
but I had no idea that they would be such a big hit.
She adores the goats.
I mean, let's just talk about how important you are
to all of us as an actor.
I mean, it's true.
Kevin Bacon, oh, my goodness,
you have enriched and enhanced our lives
character by character.
And now "City on a Hill," your character, Jackie,
can be immoral and even, you know, a little slimy
and yet you are totally rooting for him.
How do you pull that off as an actor?
Because that is so difficult to do.
All I try to do is stay true
to who I think this person is
and just turn them into a human being.
Because Jackie has so many terrible qualities,
but he's not a monster.
He's an actual human being.
And that's the thing that I just try to focus on.
Well, your performance is so exceptional in this,
and that dance is so hard to pull off and yet you do.
(lively upbeat music)